I love tailoring.
It's true, I have been in costume houses,
well, basically my first costume was a diaper
so not a lot of tailoring there.
But I have, I've been in costume houses my entire life.
And I have learned about tailoring and alteration
from these seamstresses,
it's just the greatest education
I could have ever hoped for.
And I wanna share some of that wisdom that I've learned
in a new segment,
we're calling "Tinker, Tailor, Shoulder Pad".
(audience applauds)
That's right, we're taking a serious movie
and making a play on the name.
And it's about creating an illusion for every body type,
that's empowering and makes you look forward
to getting into the clothes that actually elongate
and accentuate the features on your body
that you're most proud of.
And altering the features that you don't love as much
and making them look more to your liking because you can.
You can create extraordinary illusions.
And this is a segment about how to take your everyday look
and turn it into something really special,
tailor made just for you.
So a pair of twins wrote to us who are having trouble
getting a little suit to fit them just right.
All right, let's meet one of them now,
it's my friend Shani.
(audience applauds)
Where are you Shani?
All right, you're looking amazing.
Now let those pants drop.
Thank you.
That's right, Shani, this is how you got the suit.
What are your biggest issues with it?
I love the color, but it's way too long.
I'm a little on the shorter side.
So the pants are way too long.
I think the arms are too long.
It just feels a bit boxy.
So when I look at this silhouette
and suits are so in right now, that is the biggest trend.
I think you picked a great suit, beautiful color.
And ironically, that 80s boxy shape
is what's on trend right now.
Okay.
So how do we make it work for you?
I think this right here gives kind of a schlumpy look.
It's not cute.
It's a little masculine.
I don't like it.
I'm going, like, "Is there a tie here?"
I want to add an accessory.
I want to close it up.
I want to do something.
So let's focus there.
Also, you want the boxy shape?
I want to go right in here and we're going to create a dart.
Now a dart goes from basically these two areas.
So you want darts right here.
That's going to take it in and give you a waist.
Right.
But you want shoulders and you want a booty.
All right, then let's attack the pants.
Now you preferred a long look instead of a tapered look.
Anything to make me look taller.
Exactly, all right.
So we're going to put a heel in here.
We're gonna drop the back of this pant
and we're gonna buttercup it up like that.
Now the length of the jacket you have,
if you get a longer leg, this is gonna be better
because you elongate, you get all of this more leg.
You can afford this length.
Now I want to focus on again,
if you're not going to show some foot and ankle
you got to show skin somewhere.
Let's focus on the forearm.
It's my favorite thing to feature.
At 46 I'm like, "I give good forearm."
(Shani laughs)
Now I want to bring out your twin sister.
Okay, cause we made these changes on her.
Shay, will you come up out here?
(audience cheers)
So pretty.
Shay, you look like you're feeling it.
I love it, it's so much better, so much better.
The heel makes me look taller.
The pant leg is the perfect length
and the sleeves are just to die for.
You got to show some skin.
Now, please stand next to each other
because I want to show stand right next to each other.
Because you're safe and you're in a pod.
Look at how much taller, you're giving forearm.
The jacket length totally works.
We've taken it in, in the darts.
You've given yourself a cute preppy collar.
I'm still seeing neck.
And because I see forearm right next to it, I'm seeing skin.
You're giving toe cleavage.
It looks so perfect.
The pants are at an angle
dragged all the way to the back, but lifted in the front.
I think you guys look so good.
I'm loving it, thank you.
I love it.
What do you guys think?
It's so much better.
It's awesome.
We've got our Easter outfits now.
Yeah.
We're ready to go.
Oh my gosh, you guys have to wear this for Easter.
And we'll get yours done as well.
Now, a recommendation I have is listen,
you could go to a tailor,
now that's gonna be a little more expensive
but you can also look at your local dry cleaner.
You'll notice they have signs in the window
that say, "Tailoring."
And usually those are a little more affordable.
So look around your neighborhood
and see where a resource that fits your budget is.
And I just want to thank Shani and Shay.
Thank you.
I have had such a good time doing this with you.
Thank you so much, Drew.
Thank you.
You're both so beautiful inside and out.
And now you have an on-point, on-trend suit
to show off.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪